c'est autour d'un petit déjeuner que
françois morton lance officiellement sa
campagne à guyancourt
conseiller municipal depuis 2014 est
maire depuis mai 2010 neuf l'homme
politique veut se présenter aux
élections municipales de mars prochain
pour rencontrer très régulièrement et au
quotidien l'ensemble des abonnés des
habitants de bus en cours
je sais qu'ils apprécient effectivement
les actions et les réalisations mises en
place durant ce dernier mandat c'était
déjà le cas dans les mandats précédents
mais il s'avère que je n'étais pas élu à
l'époque donc je mais j'assume
totalement ce bilan et on en est
particulièrement fier françois morton à
50 ans sera le chef de file de
guyancourt pour tous une liste divers
gauche reconduite pour la troisième fois
moi je suis un homme de gauche je l' ai
toujours été
il s'avère que je n'adhère à aucun parti
politique si ça avait été le cas je
n'aurais eu aucune raison de m'en cacher
mais ça n'est pas le cas par contre je
suis un homme de gauche et donc
l'étiquette logique est celle de divers
gauche pendant ce mandat la liste qu en
cours pour tous a subi quelques
secousses ont 6 ans trois maires se sont
succédé à la tête de la commune avant
françois morton françois de ligne en
2016 et marie-christine le tarnec en
avril 2019 ont quitté leur poste de
maire c'est un peu inédit à 1 3 mer
durant un mandat bon ça n'arrive pas à
chaque fois
voilà c'est comme ça ce sont les aléas
de la vie pour moi ce n'est pas un sujet
et ça n'est pas un sujet pour les
habitants de la ville la liste
définitive avec 50% de renouvellement
sera connu d'ici fin janvier début
février 2020 françois morton devrait
être posée à rodolphe baril de la liste
ensemble agissons pour lui en cours à
grégory pas de nouvel élan du en cours
et olivier paréja de décidons ensemble
pour guyancourt